hello everyone
my name is kajindra deshpande i am
working as aston professor at kls gupta
instead of technology india
today i will be delivering a talk on
inventing curriculum using python and
specie
this project is supported by google
cloud under gcp research credits program
in today's talk we are going to discuss
about
uh curriculum and introduction text
summarization
then two python libraries specie and
ecstasy
and their features then our experiment
regarding the curriculum generation
then finally the conclusion
let us first have look at few
definitions of curriculum
which are listed on university delivers
web page
curriculum is nothing but a course of
study that will enable the learner to
acquire specific
knowledge and skills a curriculum
is the combination of instructional
practices
learning experiences and students
performance assessment
that are designed to bring out and
evaluate the target learning outcomes of
a particular course
curriculum is what the school is
attempting to teach
which might include social behaviors as
well as content and thinking skills
a selection of information segregated
into disciplines and
courses typically designed to achieve a
specific educational objective
the curriculum is the program of
instruction
it should be based on both standards and
best practice research
it should be the framework that teachers
use to plan instruction for their
students curriculum can be both written
and unwritten
in our work we are focusing only on
written curriculum
we are not focusing on oral or unwritten
curriculum
because we need data for our
project which is only possible through
written curriculum
[Music]
now on this slide you are saying the
structure of undergraduate engineering
programs
in india it's defined by aicte
that is all india council for technical
education
which is the body which defines the
structure for
engineering education and other
professional courses
in india especially the engineering
programs
now if you see this slide it's a
structure for undergraduate
engineering program for computer science
students
now if you look at this slide here
it includes different types of
courses uh for example it has basic
science courses engineering science
courses
professional uh core courses
professionalism courses
then open subjects then project work
then also the
mandatory courses on environmental
sciences then induction
program and so on so basically the
objective of the program is to
uh prepare students for better career
prostration industry and it focuses on
overall
development of a student
now this is a sample curriculum for
web technologies the subject
for diploma courses in india so if you
see here the syllabus content is divided
into different units
specifically five units in the first
unit
uh students will study about
introduction to world wide web then
in second unit they will study about the
web systems architecture
and from third unit onwards they are
going to study few
uh technologies which will help them to
develop
web applications for example you can see
here they are studying javascript they
are studying
advanced scripting concepts
like um html css xml
and introduction to web services and
finally the php which is nothing but the
server
server-side
programming language
now in this slide you can see here
it's a job posting
on indeed website so
if you look at the description they have
mentioned some
keywords which are the
desired qualifications and the
requirements of the employer
for example you can see here it is
mentioned ui for the web and mobile
applications but if you compare this
with the syllabus mobile applications is
missing
then similarly it's also mentioned that
the knowledge of jquery and bootstrap
is appreciated again these things are
missing in our syllabus
then this is another job posting on the
same website indeed
dot co dot in so here also
you can see here they are expecting uh
technology such as again material ui
react angular
view or web pack and also the knowledge
of um
jet up so many things are missing in the
syllabus so basically there is a gap
between the uh syllabus content we teach
to the students and the job requirement
so the main objective of our project is
to
reduce this gap and make the students
more employable
[Music]
now our project is based on the
concept of text summarization so let us
first discuss
what is text summarization and different
types and then let's move to the
our project so text summarization can be
defined as
shortening long pieces of text by
applying the computational methods
so basically what happens is you will be
given
pages of information and from that piece
of information either you have to
extract
important sentences or you have to
generate
new information
from those pages now
your text summarization can be divided
into two types
one is extraction and second one is
abstraction so
both the techniques have been explained
on the right hand side how they
work so in the first part extract to
summarizing technique is
explained so what happens in extractive
summarization technique is
you will be given a text which will be
having
n sentences and after applying
computational methods you are going to
generate this subset of sentences
okay so to generate the subset of
sentences you need to
perform some some steps such as
tokenization
then calculate the word frequency then
pick those sentences which have the
higher
word frequencies and so on so basically
you will end up in generating
only the subsets of sentences you will
not be able to generate the new
information
then next you have abstract
summarization technique in absolute
summarization technique what happens is
you will be given again
and sentences same information as in
case of uh previous case
but here after applying computational
methods you will be able to generate new
sentences
which may not be just a subset
okay you will be able to generate
new information now if you
compare both the methods extra to
summarization technique has the
advantage that
you can get the results quickly it is
very easy to
implement whereas after summarization
is hard to implement but
the results are more closer to the real
world it is not just speaking
the few sentences so it can generate
or it has the true ability to generate a
new information which is not possible
with
extraction now the better approach will
be
to use the merits of
both extraction as well as abstraction
techniques
so pointer generator network is the
uh method which actually uses the
advantages of both extra summarizing
technique and abstract to generate
abstract summarization technique so
pointers are generated using extra
summation technique we are going to
identify the
keywords then based on these keywords
new information will be generated which
is performed in the abstraction steps
so in our project we are using pointer
generator network
method now to implement
to write the software the first
important
challenge was to build a data set so
data set was not present so we built our
own data set
so we visited a few uh
job listing sites like stack overflow
indeed now create.com and so on
then we search for few job postings
there
then copy those job postings into our
text file so in that way we have created
the data set of
job postings now we also need a data set
of
syllabus of a few subjects
here the next step in second step
you have to remove the unwanted stop
words unwanted words numbers
punctuation marks and unrelated words
because these will unnecessarily
contribute to the
[Music]
speed okay your
performance will be affected if you
don't remove
these things so that's why you need to
remove
all the stopwatch punctuation marks and
all unrelated words
then in the third step you need to
tokenize words and sentences
in fourth step compute the word
frequency
and sentence score so here by what
frequency you need to count the
frequency of uh single words frequency
of
uh two words that is diagram
so then frequency of three consecutive
words
okay so basically frequency of single
words frequency of
two consecutive words frequency of three
consecutive words and so on
okay so when you compute the frequency
of
consecutive words actually you are
setting a context here
and you are trying to identify
different components of
a syllabus of a particular domain
the next select sentences with high
scores and concatenate them
then sort the words in descending order
of frequency so this is
important because we have to pick only
few words we need not have to uh
check for all the words so i can pick
only top 10 words top 20 words and so on
for our comparison the next extract the
top-end words or word combinations from
the previous step and
compare them with the syllabus of a
particular subject so here we need to
use
some metrics such as rogue
then after seventh step we will be left
with two choices
either refine the syllabus or wasting
subject with new keywords if there are
only few keywords then we can
consider including them into our
syllabus
if there are more keywords then the
software may propose a new
subject entirely
now to implement this we had used
special library which is industrial
strength
natural language processing library
which is available
in python and it's also free and open
source
library species is designed specifically
for
production use and helps you build
applications that
process and understand large volumes of
text
it can be used to build information
extraction or natural language
understanding systems
or to pre-process text for deep learning
spacey is not a research software it's
not a platform it's not a
api it's not a company it's also not a
chatbot engine
if you want more information on species
how to install and
some code examples then you can visit
our website space dot io
and explosion dot ai is a company which
actually
built this special library they also
have
two more libraries think and prodigy
so you will find more information on
explosion.ai website
[Music]
then spacey is very
beautiful library and you can have a
look at the
features so it offers non-distributed
tokenization and
named recognition it is supported
for more than 61 plus languages okay
other than
english then 46 statistical models for
16 languages are available
and pre-trained word vectors which will
help us to improve the performance
state of the art speed easy deep
learning integration
part of speech tagging you can identify
nouns pronouns etc here
then labeled dependency parsing syntax
driven sentence
segmentation built-in visualizers for
syntax and
ner that is named entity recognition
convenient string to hash mapping
export to numpy data is efficient binary
serialization
easy model packaging and deployment then
robust
rigorously evaluated accuracy the recent
versions accuracy that is spacey 3.x
versions accuracy is around 92 percent
the next library is the text ac which is
built on top of uh spacey
so it basically allows us to extend the
functionalities of
spacing so for example here
it is built on the high performance
species library
so with the fundamentals tokenization
part of speech tagging dependency
parsing etc
delegated to another library that is all
these features are available in
spacey so destacy focuses primarily on
tasks that come before and follow after
for example engram analysis
functionality is not available in spacey
but it is available in text testing
so after performing basic tasks using
species you can move to texture c for
engram analysis and other advanced
features
so you can again refer the specified url
to
get the more information on texas
library
then next
you can have a look at accessory
features so you can access
spaces through convenient methods for
working with one or many documents and
extend its functionality through
custom extensions and automatic language
identification
for applying the right specified plan
for the text then download data sets
with both text content and metadata
and easily stream data to and from
disk in many common formats then clean
normalized and explore raw text before
processing it with spacing
and flexibly extract words engrams noun
chunks
entities acronyms key terms and other
elements of interest
from processed documents then compare
strings
sets and documents by a variety of
similarity metrics
then tokenize and vectorize documents
then train interpret and visualize topic
models
compute a variety of text readability
statistics including
flash skin set grade level smog index
and multilingual flash
reading is now let's uh have a look at
the source code what we have written for
our experiment
so we need two libraries one is special
and second one is collections
now on the fourth line you can see here
there is a
set which
is nothing but the group of unwanted
ones which
we want to remove so this set is nothing
but the
list of unwanted words which are out of
context and we
simply don't want them for
our processing then next on sixth line
we are loading the english
language model which is a small
english language model there is also
large english language model but it
takes
a lot of space we can experiment
with larger model later and we'll
see how it's going to affect our
experiment
then dataset.txt is a file
in which the job postings are stored
then we are going to read the
content from dataset.txt then apply
nlp function to create mydoc
object so basically here we are creating
an lpa
object so that we can perform operations
on it
then for our information we are trying
to print the
number of tokens uh before
pre-processing and after pre-processing
so i'll show you in the output how it's
going to affect pre-processing
then on 15th line we are going to remove
or we are removing the stopwatch we are
removing the punctuation marks
we are removing the digits we are among
the white spaces we are removing the
numbers
we are removing urls and also the emails
then on 17th line we are performing
limitization so limitization is nothing
but
uh converting the
tokens into their basic form for example
let us consider the
terms player playing player
etc so the root form of
all these terms is play so we are
converting
all the tokens to their root forms
again this will help us to
reduce the number of tokens then on 19th
line we are converting
all our tokens to lower case letters
again it is for
better pre-processing there
there can be there is a possibility that
you may have tokens with
mixed cases say for example html or css
it might be written in css
it might be written in upper case or it
might be written in lowercase but
in computing terms they will be treated
differently we don't want them to read
them differently we want them to treat
them same so we are converting them to
uniform
case in this case it is lowercase
then next on 21st line we are removing
all the unwanted terms which we have
listed in the
fourth line so that that is just an
indicative list
we have to actually create a huge list
of unwanted list
then next on 30 second line we are
actually computing the frequency of
single words for this we are using
counter method from the collections
so it is going to generate the uh
list of word frequencies in descending
order directly
so you will not have to do much here
then
in 35th line we are picking top
10 words from the
word frequency list then in 40th line
we are actually uh
computing the word frequency of uh two
neighboring words
okay then in 43rd line we are picking
top 10
uh diagrams in 48th
line we are again computing the word
frequency of
three neighboring words that is three
consecutive words
and in 51st line we are picking up top
10
trigrams
then on 58 line you can see that there
is a
statement written syllabus is equal to
so some terms are written again note
here that syllabus will also be having
stop words and different things again
you need to remove you need to
do pre-processing on syllabus content
also
so again this is an integrative list you
can see here that
there are few single words and there are
few
multiple words that means we have grams
and diagrams here
okay then next on 60th line
we are actually performing the
comparison and we are
computing how many words how many grams
are appearing in our syllabus
then on 60 is third line we are
computing how many diagrams are
appearing in our syllabus and similarly
on 16
uh ninth line we are computing how many
trigrams are appearing in our syllabus
so the entire source code repository is
available and the url is specified
you can visit this url for the source
code
now this is the output now you can see
here when we run this
first time it is displaying that before
pre-processing there are 257 tokens
after pre-processing you can see the
number of tokens is significantly
reduced it is just one node
so that's why i'm saying pre-processing
is very very important
it is going to affect your performance
if you don't pre-process the
data set properly and it's also
displaying the
uh token list after preprocessing then
next
in the output you can see what frequency
of grams now you can see here the
counter
method is displaying the top words
in uh descending order that is highest
frequency words first and least
frequency words last so you can see here
html is appearing seven times
web five times word press four times css
three times
so we have to pick top ten words from
this list now
so you can see here it's available on
the next line so top 10 graphs html web
wordpress css and so on jquery bootstrap
and so on
and similarly what frequency of diagrams
so
in diagrams also you can see here that
html and css in combination they are
appearing twice then similarly web and
mobile they are appearing
twice and so on now similarly we have to
compute we have extra top 10 diagrams
after switching top 10 diagrams
go for what frequency of trigrams that
is three consecutive words
appearing together so
then after that extract the top 10
trigrams
now once it is done you have to compare
it with the syllabus and find out the
percentage now you can see here
when we compare uh top 10
grams with the syllabus there are only
five atoms which are matching
and there is only one term one diagram
which is matching
with the syllabus so this is how this
project works still a lot of work is
remaining we are continuously
working on it and we are continuously
improving our work
so any suggestions you can always put it
on our
github repository so that will help us
to improve this
further
then the conclusion is that to achieve
better results using national language
processing one of the important factor
is
pre-processing of a document using
pointer generator network we can balance
the advantages or disadvantages of
extractive or obstructive
summarization to get the better results
and need to experiment with
non-professional courses and with other
than english language
such as indic languages or maybe some
other languages also
thank you
you